so I always like to talk about you know
executing against your DNA and one thing
I want to talk about to you about is
really embracing all of your DNA
even if it's against the principles
principles not princesses principles of
your business and so my principles are
put your head down hustle
kill it right focus community all that
well what happens when part of your DNA
is distractions or the need for a rush
or something new little new love in your
life that's kind of how I am I'm a big
fan of building new things I love that
and so here comes along many of you who
might have heard about this my brother
AJ and I and Joe stump over at Digg put
together a t-shirt search engine right
so like what's that all about hold on
one second so like you know different
t-shirts you know t-shirts right like
good old-fashioned like t-shirts um that
we do like you know different things
like this it looks this Pandora maybe um
yeah good job anyway um we created a
t-shirt search engine my brother came up
with it he pitched it to me I loved it I
thought it was there was a need it was
it was awesome and we launched his site
and I don't quite have been on it over
the last 10 days I mean it's getting a
lot of buzz you know Boing Boing and
Lifehacker and TechCrunch it's super
humbling you know it's super exciting
and there's a lot of adrenaline and I
just want to tell people that you know
what don't be scared of distractions
it's bad to be super strength spread
thin but sometimes that's just your DNA
and that's who I am you know you need
that little shot to get excited again
about what you do and so you know being
distracted is not always the worst thing
in the world you just have to manage it
at some level and have other people that
are actually doing things you can't do
it all yourself obviously having AJ in
the trenches allows me to you know
hightail and get in there and do some
things but not worry about a day-to-day
same thing with my business Wine Library
the retail side right I mean I'm not
there in the trenches day-to-day anymore
because I'm so focused on Wine Library
TV and so I I just feel that a lot of
people look down especially the classic
business of a Oh Gary or Sprint in um I
just want my DNA to be my brand right
and my DNA says you know what I need to
get excited about things randomly out of
nowhere and if they're exciting and I
feel like I'm into it I'm gonna hustling
so I've been up to to 3:00 in the
morning you know
bags you know playing with please dress
me and see how I said playing see how
that was the natural thing you know I'm
working with my face off but it's
playing it's that excitement and then
you get your nut off as they say and you
can't refocused on what you want so
don't be scared of distractions I'm
still here